Hello, this is Dr. Cutters, and we know that when people, it diagnosed with cancer, it becomes a very scary situation.
It's not something most people are expecting, and
it's easy to get lost in
just what your doctor is telling you to do. Most people don't think, well, what should I do alternatively also?
And I applaud you for even viewing this video because you are thinking that way.
When you're diagnosed with one of the blood cancers, like lymphoma and leukemia,
some
tend to be known as more rapidly progressing cancers, and
sometimes we need to use standards of care like chemotherapy and things.
But how do we know what else to add to the puzzle?
Because I really believe, and I think you listening to this do believe too,
that if you do add alternative care to whatever else you're going to do,
you can have a better outcome, and I think statistics do show that.
So, what am I supposed to add from an alternative perspective?
What specific nutrition? What supplements?
Sometimes we get bombarded from well-meaning friends and loved ones.
So, what to take, and what not to take, and it gets very confusing.
Well, that's what we're here for you to help you walk that pathway.
What supplement should I take? What diet should I be following?
What herbal or nutrition should I be doing, and is there some equipment that can help me?
We'll help walk you through this. Whether you become a patient or not,
please utilize our website. Download all my books. They're all free online.
Please look at that. Educate yourself. I think the more educated you are, the more empowered you are,
I do believe that that is what God has called us to do, is to not be ignorant about these things
as well as scriptural things. Ultimately, we want your best. We want you to have success.
We want the best quality of life for you. So, no, regardless of whether you choose care
in our office or not, that we will be praying for you.